warum hat die bank viele fans keinen
grund vorstellen plastik selbstbewusst
sind herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video und heute ist ein ganz besonderer
tag denn meine mutter hat mich besucht
hier noch besonderes für die meisten ist
es völlig normal aber ich meine mutter
lieben kilometer auseinander und ich hab
gar nicht so viel besuch hier und ich
will das spiel von deutschland
es ist das zweite mal innerhalb von vier
jahren als meine mutter mich besucht und
deswegen nehmen das zum anlass heute ein
video zusammen mit meiner mutter zu
machen laut bitte hier hat mir zu diesem
zweck frage auf wird dargestellt wie
aber jetzt nicht beantworten werden
ihnen gemeint sondern meine mutter sagte
zu werden ich bin okay alles deutlichen
folgen fotos und wenn ich mich zu wehren
wusste ich gebe mir die erste freie
compagnie warst du als kind oder
jugendlicher anstrengend anstrengend
gottes willen nein auf keinen fall ein
absolutes wunschkind lange gewartet
endlich gekommen und sonnenschein von
anfang die leute ja also ich war
tatsächlich das erste kind deswegen auch
ich einfach mal dass ich auch in münchen
war ich einfach der unterschied dass das
kind auch das gewicht hat oder nicht
wenn es da ist ist es da und ängstlich
schaut das brot gibt ihm was zuerst aber
weiter anstrengen ist ja sowas echt
anstrengend doch sehr anstrengend sein
bruder in kleinen bruder auf eine ganz
besondere art und weise gegeben und
geherzt und auch nie irgendwie gehauen
oder zu mannheim gottes willen mörder
sagte zu - voll und durchhalten mich zu
fragen von yasmin el castillo und warf
seinen orden kind oder regierte chaos
aus dem zimmer ein wenn ich ehrlich sein
soll und alle anderen mütter mal weg
werden dann muss ich sagen ich weiß es
nicht weil ich hab immer aufgeräumt es
jasper johns man ja und nein ich habe es
dazu kommen lassen weil ich dachte du
machst es ähnlich nächste frage von
aviva von sebastian erstes wort
muss hierbei nehmen also vielfach nichts
geändert
mama papa auf keinen fall ich weiß ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen es gibt nicht
nur sebastian es gibt noch andere
ich glaube es geht um essen zu helfen
eine gute frage dass eine gute feier ist
für mich eine antwort von 11 geht müsst
euch führung mit wie vielen jahren hast
du das erste mal alkohol sollen ich hab
ich erstmal gut dass man sich jetzt
antworten ich denn da überhaupt darüber
einig sagen ja also ich meine da costa
der in frühestens drei zugriff muss mit
13 14
es gibt doch genau das stimmt das hier
ist keine frage von rehna escape züchter
ist warum hat so viele fans können wir
führen grund vorstellen
das alles mit einem mehr haben oder
warum also lustig lustig selbstbewusst
sind hässlich aber über transparente
erziehen wir machen das weil die poren
ein drachen netter typ
okay diese frage leute von jasmin und
die geht in die richtung mädels die
frage nämlich wie viele freunde damit
für freundin oder medien die schon harte
landung spies noch des blue und also
öffentlich nur noch ins also ich denke
der fun fun und offenes ende 112 5 also
wie weit man gesehen in der stadt oder
nein von mir auf jeden fall natürlich
schwingt da wirklich so ich hatte gar
nicht gar nicht so glücklich seine
freundin muss die richtige noch kommt
wenn die richtige sagt dann schreibt
einfach an diese e-mail hier nächstes
lage von kindern kaka war devil fest
also eher als er geboren wurde so aus
wir
ein sumo-ringer gehalt als viereinhalb
kilo gewogen waren der humor pur und der
hatte so reiste packendes aufnahme wie
chinese der geburt hat sie aber dann
gelegt ja überhaupt beim lachen mit ihm
er soll und muss auch sagen ich war so
bis 35 filtern hat sich vor ort
also ja es stimmt aber dann hat für dich
dafür interessiert und ich da deine wege
bekannt und hat sich verändert und
willst du weniger gegessen oder richtige
mehr sport gemacht weil genau das macht
den sport gibt's gewicht nach unten muss
das kleine insekt datum ich hab so mit
13 14 glaube ich 95 kilo untrainiert
gewogen auf meter 58 ist 185 km sports
ist auch wenig muskeln 85 kilo 350 meter
90 groß deutlicher muskel und wiegt
jetzt so hoch wächst nach ich die macht
ich also dreams und natürlich beispiel
wasser zur debatte in der kindheit als
berufswunsch klar dass alles klappt er
wollte lokomotivführer erlernen echt ja
ich habe früher immer genannt ich hatte
irgendwie einen namen irgendwas martin
pape gesagt muttertag etwas diplomaten
muttertag gehen oder eine alte
lokomotive logo immer so irgendwann doch
noch als lokomotive oder fax 030 34
motive blieben unter wasser 030 303 weil
ich mir ist ob ich selbst mir wasser nur
drei gehören ja alle hilfsgüter name
wasser 03 chf
ich glaube sascha 03 was ja das war der
lokomotivführer und ich habe euch meine
mutter die video nicht gezeigt welches
wie bisher finde ich mag nicht so gerne
aber ihr habt ihre geheiminformationen
bekommen und in diesem sinne leute euch
das video gefallen hat könnt ihr hier
oben links alles video abchecken hier
und mein
abonnieren hier oben leute das absolute
spezialangebot die neueste folge was das
geht von dem format von mir und
multimedia checken viele zuschauer und
un chef